Lissa Milano very excitable left-wing
figure and actress she just took to
Twitter to beg her many followers for
money for her kids baseball team tweets
out go fund me my son's baseball team is
raising money for their Cooper Town trip
you know Baseball Hall of Fame any
amount would be so greatly appreciated
you can read more about the team and
make a donation here okay got almost 12
million views it's a bad look it's a bad
look because Alyssa Milano is really
really rich unless she's completely
mishandled her money Alysa Milano has
millions and millions prob tens of
millions of dollars over the course of
her life and she doesn't need to be
begging her followers to chip in a penny
this not a good look very famous very
wealthy Hollywood celebrities should be
donating not just to their kids baseball
teams but to other Charities as well